a clinical case means when somebody
be a way for the fungus to spread from
one person to another
once Canada RS
is
the question you are asking is very very
important because as you mentioned this
One hospital have a lot of colonization
which means people have deceased or this
fungus on their skin
if this is the case then it's very
important to start following rules to
try to wash hands disinfect different
surfaces to make sure we get rid of it
because we don't want that then to spend
to other patients however in the
hospital we have a lot of infections
this means that the organism already got
hold of a patient and it's causing
disease and this means anybody who is
visiting this patient they want to make
sure they stay at a distance wash hands
make sure you don't really touch
surfaces the bedding the table in in the
room and really most importantly if we
have somebody with the infection it will
be very important to put them in their
own room separate from other patients so
that we really stop a transfer of this
infection from one person to the other
think fungus for example if a patient is
in hospital and he has or she has an
infection it's very important to take
the sample send it to the lab for
testing but also what we tend when we
think a person has infection the
clinicians they give antibiotics if an
antibiotic does not improve
the symptoms of a patient in four days
then please start thinking fungus
because it could be fungus and not
bacteria that causing the disease and
this message is very very important as
medical mycology or people who study
fungus always Advocate please think
fungus